un po
bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj non potevo non
poteva assolutamente non fare onenight
air france i tre siano ancora capito
come si pronuncia fatto 60 volte sto
gioco è uscito il 3 d one aitef l'anti
dopo aver giocato a poppi playtime ci
mancava un horror serio non è giusto che
sono un po di giorni che dormono
vogliamo mica continuare così per molto
mi sembra corretto nei miei confronti
non quindi sopravvive fino alle 6 del
mattino fino qua ci siamo allora ragazzi
quale the frame sì ma un attimo
madonna che si quanto fatto bene
stavolta
non mi interessa quello che dici allora
ragazzi quale the plant ii come white e
freddi sono che c'è non è freddi e
franti valutario capita e tutto ciò che
posso dirvi di questo gioco di solito
salve si è alzato ma c'è la temperatura
cos'è la temperatura scusami
aiuto non capisco cosa vuol fare
si è spostato lo zio dove è sparito dove
potevo fare qui aiuto di b non capisco a
devo fare le foto ho capito ma cosa devo
farle a cosa le devo fare le foto non
era molto chiaro questo tipo
acclimatarmi
quindi io ho freddo solo che rimane
rimanendo qua rischio che è che
mitighino quello succedere credo ok
quindi va beh rimango quindi si sono qua
sono safe sostanzialmente spero perché
sono un assenso guarda quanto sigilla
sta qua davanti
quanto il c lo zio con la faccia come
faccio a respingerlo come lo respingo
apposta
ce l'ho fatta provare e questo cos'è
scusa a pois che può anche uscire al
condotto va bene allora può uscire sia
dal condotto che dal corridoio va bene
nel frattempo mi sta morendo di freddo è
tutto chiaro ragazzi quindi io devo
andare a sinistra per recuperare la
temperatura tornare lì per falli le foto
perché se li faccio le foto lui si
vergogna e se ne va via solo che devo
vederlo per porca [ __ ] chi è questo
giorno ecco non lo vedo più
capitano è riuscito lo stesso
così che devo fare
nessuna fotografia coltre cosa devo fare
scusa 1 e gli devo fare le foto l'altro
cosa vi devo fare non gli posso fare le
foto con flash che si incazzava bene e
che faccio lo guardo poi tanto è un
portale ma ma che razza di questo è
questo c'è stranissimo c'è un portale
comunque lo vedo
c'è qualcosa lei in fondo è sparito
eccolo blocchi non li vedo ancora vi
vedo ancora come ho detto ci sono due
occhi qua clubti che se la prende comoda
come se niente fosse
non ho ancora capito come devos comini
dovrei riuscire a schivare lo stronzo
qua che francesco ha nessuna fotografia
e vabbè ma come fa nome da
non avevamo visto la temperatura
ok allora flight di l'ho mandato via e
fin qua ci siamo come faccio a togliere
il flash della fotocamera non la tolgo
cioè non lo tolgo mi devo rilevare dalle
palle vengo qua non lo so però non ho
capito come schivare il tipo golfrè
cosa devo fare questo qua cosa devo fare
non lo faccio non lo faccio sto qua
rimango qui finchè osserva via sarà data
era forse era da funziona così chi è
questo ho chiesto 100 aiuto
cosa ancora che palle questo gesto
stay away the way o no scherzavo
mi sono accorto della puttanata quando
l'ho fatta ovviamente c'è il tizio che
quando che il portale è collegato con la
caldaia perché giustamente la caldaia è
rifornita da dall inferno quindi è per
questo che effettivamente ciò il caldo e
non devo andare quando c'è il tizio che
sfrutta tutto chiaro nei miei neuroni
che sono due l'hanno capito tutti e due
guarda quanto ai donghi va fax toccano
equa incredibile allora abbiamo capito
che uno deve andare il fuoco che sono lo
schifo l'altro non ci devo andarmi nel
fuoco e flauti gli devo fare le foto di
tutto chiaro né mancherà ancora uno che
credo che sia quello del condotto e non
so chi sia quindi quando c'è il tizio
del portale io devo andare qua sto
morendo di freddo molto tutto chiaro in
realtà non è così difficile si è
difficile ma una volta capito ce la
posso fare non so come funziona quello
del condotto io immagino che doveva
farli foto anche nel condotto non so se
hai sempre flauti magari sempre perché
vedo che anche nel condotto e lo posso
illuminare facendo le foto no
quindi secondo me devo fare le foto qua
non so come ma devo fare foto da questo
qua io qua non ci posso andare ok adesso
mi dirà stay away e io staro away
lo zio sanno tutti al centro con quello
che fa stay away allora me ne vado a
destra sono andato a destra
sta succedendo cose ci sono i due e
mezzo cosa devo fare adesso
posso andare a sinistra
ok non photocall flash faccia faccia
fotografare ciò che perfetto dalla
sinistra tutto ok
la situa e salva la situa e salva sulle
due del mattino perfetto una delle vie
di là e c'è qualcuno nel condotto
e venere non c'è
non va non c'è nessuno faceva fatto caso
cosa devo fare qui
sta morendo di freddo della sinistra
oddio speriamo che lo sfrutti tizio che
sfrutta il tizio dai no
chi è che non so quando non so quando
arriva lo zio scatto foto a cazzo perché
tanto eccolo e non devo andare a
sinistra ok sto attento flauti stay away
sono guai sono questo no way sono alle
hawaii quegli uccelli perfetto con il
condotto non c'è flauti e qua il tipo è
sempre sì però più freddo o che perfetto
miri figlio un attimo
vado da flam ti aspetta che non so se
c'è o che vai perfetto ok buono buono
buono buono quest'anno buona giocata
quest'anno gran giocata attenzione
adesso sto qua non so quanto perché il
pagliaccio sta a destra provando a
vedere se c'è non credo
dov'è merda quello entrato nel con da
torino e pagliacci qua il tizio ok
allora spetta ai pre napoli e dvd caldo
bene quello entrato nelle condotte
attenzione attenzione
merda dove flauti non lo vedo equa fra
mieli il pagliaccio e scomparso scompari
sciuto proprio questo sta qua
merda vai veloce
mai madonna quanto tempo ci volta dove
saranno look no look mamma mia che
giocata va via adesso io lo zio a suo
tempo per un po
perfetto vai adesso vivo lo zio al
centro io me ne vado a destra perfetto
non so se c'è qualcuno qua però
cazzo non so se c'è qualcuno sole 4 del
mattino ragazzi beh è un bel punteggio è
teoricamente è passato no
posso no
che palle
io continuo a scattare perché non so se
c'è gente e vabbè cosa devo fare qua
cos'era questa roba
gli occhi devono essere accecati che li
devo devo fotografarli quelli ma cos'è
erano gli occhi dai cose erano gli occhi
non l'avevo ancora visti lo fare la foto
va bene comunque non è andata male però
possiamo sempre fare un altro tentativo
ragazzi la prossima volta fatemi sapere
se vi piace il video è stato bellissimo
munque veramente fatto bene quale da
tanti sono però vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
come senso di omicidio il momento non mi
piace anche per i social come
descrizione sono stato si schieri e noi
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo virus
è la ragazzi
[Musica]